Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada. So the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to NetZero. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions in average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our NetZero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at pathwaysalliance.ca
加拿大的油砂开采活动产生了大量的碳排放。因此，六家最大的公司联手合作，在实现净零排放的道路上迈出步伐。我们投资于技术和创新，已将每桶原油的平均排放量减少了22%。我们与政府合作，创造并保障就业岗位，并正在开发全球最大的碳捕集与封存设施之一。我们的净零计划正在实施中，我们正通过多种途径取得进展。请访问 pathwaysalliance.ca 了解我们的计划。
Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. 147 Easy Street was a typical semi-detached terrace home for Melbourne's inner city suburbs. Its front door opened to a narrow hallway with three bedrooms leading off to the right. A bathroom sat at the end of the hall which also doubled as the laundry. Another door led to a living room and modest kitchen which opened to a small backyard encased by a fence. From the yard, a gate granted access to a side laneway that separated number 147 from a neighbouring property and led out into the street.
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本集的节目说明。147号Easy街是墨尔本内城区典型的半独立式排屋。前门通向一条狭窄的走廊，右侧有三间卧室。走廊尽头是一间浴室，同时也兼作洗衣房。另一扇门通向客厅和简朴的厨房，厨房通向一个被栅栏围住的小后院。从院子里，一扇门可以通往一条侧巷，这条巷子将147号与邻近的房产隔开，并通向街道。
On Thursday, January 13, 1977, next door neighbour Janet waited anxiously in the laneway. At her side was a German shepherd cross puppy named Mischka. The dog belonged to the two young women who lived at 147 Easy Street, Suzanne Armstrong and Susan Bartlett. Janet and her housemate Alona had found Mischka wandering the street two days earlier, but knocks and calls to 147 had gone unanswered. Janet and Alona had kept Mischka secured in their backyard waiting for the two soos to come looking for her, but no one did. At one stage, Alona peered over the fence into the backyard of 147 and noticed a rear door leading into the kitchen was open and a light was on. Her worries increased the following day when she overheard the distressed sound of crying through the home's shared wall. It was Suzanne's 16 month old son.
1977年1月13日星期四，隔壁邻居珍妮特焦急地在巷子里等待。她身边是一只名叫米什卡的德国牧羊犬混血幼犬。这只狗属于住在Easy街147号的两名年轻女子：苏珊·阿姆斯特朗和苏珊·巴特利特。珍妮特和她的室友阿洛娜两天前发现米什卡在街上游荡，但敲门和呼喊147号却无人应答。珍妮特和阿洛娜把米什卡关在后院，等着那两个“苏”来找它，但一直没人来。有一次，阿洛娜隔着栅栏往147号的后院看，发现通往厨房的后门开着，灯也亮着。第二天，当她隔着两家共用的墙听到屋内传来痛苦的哭声时，她的担忧加剧了。那是苏珊16个月大的儿子。
It was unusual for his cries to go ignored as Suzanne was a very attentive and affectionate mother. At their wits end, Alona and Janet headed next door to investigate. They bypassed the front door. A note they'd pinned their days earlier informing the women that their dog was loose remained untouched. Once in the side laneway, Janet waited with Mischka while Alona entered 147's backyard and disappeared through the open kitchen door. A short while later, Alona rushed from the house in a panic. Call the police, she said. They're dead. It took two calls to 000 and over 20 minutes before a single police officer finally arrived at 147 Easy Street.
他的哭声被忽视是很不寻常的，因为苏珊是一位非常细心和慈爱的母亲。束手无策之下，阿洛娜和珍妮特前往隔壁查看。她们绕过了前门。几天前她们贴在门上告知那两位女性狗跑丢了的字条依然原封不动。进入侧巷后，珍妮特带着米什卡在外面等，阿洛娜进入147号的后院，从敞开的厨房门消失了。片刻之后，阿洛娜惊慌失措地从屋里冲出来。她说：“报警，她们死了。”在拨打了两次000报警电话并等待了20多分钟后，一名警察终于抵达了Easy街147号。
Alona met him outside and led him into 147's backyard via the side laneway along the same route she had taken almost half an hour earlier. Mischka's vacant kennel sat under the kitchen window near the open back door. The officer stepped inside into the narrow kitchen with its bric-a-brac filled shelves and onwards to the living room. So far, nothing seemed out of the ordinary. There was a couch, television and record player. Everything appeared neat and in order. The officer reached the dimly lit hallway and peered towards the front door. At the end of the hall, lying face down next to the door was the bloodied body of Susan Bartlett. She was fully clothed in a nightdress with numerous stab wounds to her arms, hands, legs and upper torso.
阿洛娜在外面迎接他，并带着他沿着半小时前走过的路线，经由侧巷进入147号的后院。米什卡空荡荡的狗窝就在敞开的后门旁边的厨房窗户下。警官走进狭窄的厨房，里面摆满了杂物架，随后进入客厅。到目前为止，一切似乎都很正常。屋里有沙发、电视和唱片机。一切看起来整洁有序。警官走到光线昏暗的走廊，向大门方向望去。在走廊尽头，脸朝下倒在门边的是苏珊·巴特利特血迹斑斑的尸体。她穿着睡衣，手臂、手部、腿部和上半身有多处刀伤。
Alongside her, the walls of the hallway were smeared and splattered with blood. Moving towards Susan's body, the officer glimpsed into the front bedroom. Inside, Susan Armstrong lay on the carpet. She was naked except for a red and white nightdress that had been pulled up around her head. Her arms, chest and chin were riddled with knife wounds and her legs were spread wide apart. Grasping the enormity of the situation, the attending officer radioed for backup. A swarm of police cars then descended on Easy Street. The Bartlett family hadn't been too pleased when Susan announced that she was moving to Collingwood in October of 1976.
在她身旁，走廊的墙壁上沾满了喷溅的血迹。警官走向苏珊的尸体，瞥了一眼前面的卧室。里面，苏珊·阿姆斯特朗躺在地毯上。她赤身裸体，只有一件红白相间的睡衣被推到了头顶。她的手臂、胸部和下巴布满了刀伤，双腿大张。意识到事态的严重性，在场的警官用无线电呼叫了增援。随后，大批警车涌向Easy街。当苏珊在1976年10月宣布她要搬到科林伍德时，巴特利特一家并不太高兴。
Located four kilometers from Melbourne's CBD, the semi-industrial area had a checkered past. Even though it was gaining popularity with students and young people looking to take advantage of the cheap rent, it still had a reputation as one of Victoria's roughest suburbs. Crime rates were high and drugs and gangs were an ongoing problem. But for 27-year-old Susan Bartlett, who went by Sue, Collingwood offered everything she needed. There was a milk bar on the corner, reliable public transport nearby, and it wasn't far from the high school where she worked as an art teacher. The house at 147 Easy Street was basic but cozy, and the rent was much more affordable than the place in nearby Richmond where she had been living previously. Furthermore, Sue was looking forward to living with her friend, 28-year-old Suzanne Armstrong.
该地区距离墨尔本中央商务区四公里，是一个半工业区，有着复杂的过去。尽管它因廉价的租金而受到学生和年轻人的欢迎，但它仍被认为是维多利亚州最混乱的郊区之一。犯罪率很高，毒品和帮派问题一直存在。但对于27岁的苏珊·巴特利特（大家都叫她苏）来说，科林伍德提供了她所需要的一切。街角有一家奶吧，附近有可靠的公共交通，而且离她担任美术老师的高中也不远。Easy街147号的房子虽然简陋但很舒适，租金也比她之前住的附近的里士满便宜得多。此外，苏很期待与她的朋友、28岁的苏珊·阿姆斯特朗住在一起。
The two knew one another from high school, having both grown up in the country town of Benalla. The women had a lot in common. Both were intelligent, creative and sociable, and they shared a love of cooking and travel. They'd recently explored the Greek islands together, proving they could live alongside one another without issue. Sue also had a great affection for Suzanne's toddler son, Gregory. By January 1977, Sue and Suzanne had been living in Collingwood together for around two months. Monday, January 10 started normally for both women. They rose early, ate breakfast together, and then went their separate ways. Suzanne bathed Gregory, and the two took off on her bicycle to visit some friends. Sue's mother was in town, and the two met to go shopping in the city.
两人从高中就认识了，都是在贝纳拉小镇长大的。她们有很多共同点。两人都很聪明、有创造力且善于交际，并且都热爱烹饪和旅行。她们最近一起探索了希腊群岛，证明了她们可以毫无问题地住在一起。苏也非常疼爱苏珊的幼儿格雷戈里。到1977年1月，苏和苏珊已经在科林伍德一起住了大约两个月。1月10日星期一，对两人来说开始得很正常。她们早起，一起吃早餐，然后各奔东西。苏珊给格雷戈里洗了澡，两人骑自行车去拜访了一些朋友。苏的母亲当时在城里，两人见面去城里购物。
Afterwards, Sue went home to work on a dress she was in the process of sewing. She was a talented seamstress who made most of her own clothes, and she intended to wear this dress on a date she had planned for Wednesday night. After working on the dress for a while, Sue began to cook dinner in preparation for company. Sue's brother Martin was a regular visitor to 147 Easy Street. Having also made the move to the big city from Benalla, he enjoyed helping his sister with tasks around the house in exchange for a home-cooked meal. Sue's stereo had recently broken, so Martin agreed to come over for dinner and then have a go at fixing it. Martin got the stereo working, and they all listened to some records, but then Sue and Suzanne said they wanted to watch television. One of their favorite shows, The Sullivan's, was about to start, and they were keen to see it once Suzanne put her son down for the night.
之后，苏回家继续缝制一件连衣裙。她是一位才华横溢的裁缝，大部分衣服都是自己做的，她打算在周三晚上的约会中穿这件裙子。在缝纫了一会儿后，苏开始做晚饭，准备招待客人。苏的哥哥马丁是Easy街147号的常客。他也从贝纳拉搬到了大城市，喜欢帮妹妹做家务，以换取一顿家常便饭。苏的音响最近坏了，所以马丁答应过来吃晚饭，顺便修一下。马丁修好了音响，他们一起听了一些唱片，但后来苏和苏珊说她们想看电视。她们最喜欢的节目之一《沙利文一家》即将开始，她们很想在苏珊哄儿子睡觉后观看。
At around 9pm, Martin bid the women farewell, with the Bartlett siblings making plans to catch up again the following week. It was an enjoyable, albeit uneventful evening. Everyone was in good spirits, and nothing seemed out of the ordinary. When Martin left, Suzanne and Sue were comfortably settled in front of the television. He would become the last person to see his sister and her friend alive. Given there were no further sightings of either of the women after Martin left, and that dog was found wandering the streets the following day, it was determined they had likely been killed sometime in the early hours of Tuesday, January 11. Neighbors didn't hear or see anything out of the ordinary, although next-door neighbor Alona recalled hearing Gregory crying for a prolonged period on Tuesday morning. This meant that the bodies of Susan Bartlett and Suzanne Armstrong lay undiscovered in their home for three days, while the young boy lay distressed and alone in his cot.
晚上9点左右，马丁向她们告别，巴特利特兄妹计划下周再聚。这是一个愉快但平淡的夜晚。每个人都心情愉快，一切看起来都很正常。马丁离开时，苏珊和苏正舒适地坐在电视机前。他成了最后一个见到他妹妹及其朋友活着的人。由于马丁离开后没有人再见过这两名女性，且第二天狗被发现独自在街上游荡，据推测她们很可能是在1月11日星期二凌晨被杀害的。邻居们没有听到或看到任何异常，尽管隔壁邻居阿洛娜回忆说，周二早上听到格雷戈里长时间地哭泣。这意味着苏珊·巴特利特和苏珊·阿姆斯特朗的尸体在她们家中被放置了三天未被发现，而那个小男孩则独自在婴儿床里感到痛苦。
Collectively, the young women had been stabbed a total of 82 times, with Sue sustaining 55 stab wounds to Suzanne's 27. The wounds were deep, having likely been inflicted using forceful rapid thrusts with a 2.5cm wide blade. Suzanne had also been raped post-mortem. However, it didn't appear that any great struggle had taken place. Other than a vase of flowers that had been knocked over, Suzanne's bedroom was in relatively neat order. The blood had pulled on the carpet above her head, several drops of blood stained her bedsheet, and a pair of her underwear lay beside her. The scene indicated that Suzanne had been reading in bed when she got up and encountered her killer, who then launched a brutal and frenzied attack. There were also smears of blood on the lamp and alarm clock next to the bed.
总的来说，这两名年轻女性总共被刺了82刀，苏被刺了55刀，苏珊被刺了27刀。伤口很深，很可能是用2.5厘米宽的刀刃猛烈快速地刺入造成的。苏珊在死后还遭到了强奸。然而，现场似乎并没有发生激烈的搏斗。除了一个被打翻的花瓶外，苏珊的卧室相对整洁。地毯上在她头部上方有血迹，床单上有几滴血，她的一件内衣掉在旁边。现场表明，苏珊当时正在床上看书，起身时遇到了凶手，随后遭到了残酷而疯狂的袭击。床边的台灯和闹钟上也有血迹。
Either Suzanne had reached over in an attempt to grab her bedside phone to call for help, or the killer had reached over to turn the lamp off. The location of Sue Bartlett's body in the hallway, just outside of Suzanne's bedroom, suggested she had likely confronted the killer after Suzanne was already dead. Sue's hands and arms were covered with the fence wounds, which explained the smears of blood on the hallway walls. Investigators believed that after killing Sue, the perpetrator returned to Suzanne's bedroom to rape her lifeless body. The attack had been so quick and savage that neither woman had any time or opportunity to seek help. Gregory was discovered in the middle room between the two women's bedrooms. He was found lying hungry in his cot, his skin pale and nappy soiled. Other than having been dehydrated and distressed for some time, he was alive and unhurt.
要么是苏珊伸手试图抓起床边的电话求救，要么是凶手伸手关掉了台灯。苏·巴特利特的尸体位于走廊里，就在苏珊卧室外，这表明她很可能是在苏珊遇害后与凶手对峙的。苏的手和手臂上布满了防御性伤口，这解释了走廊墙壁上的血迹。调查人员认为，在杀害苏之后，凶手回到了苏珊的卧室，强奸了她冰冷的尸体。袭击发生得如此迅速和残忍，以至于两名女性都没有时间或机会寻求帮助。格雷戈里是在两名女性卧室之间的中间房间被发现的。他被发现时正饿着肚子躺在婴儿床里，皮肤苍白，尿布脏了。除了脱水和痛苦了一段时间外，他活着且没有受伤。
His room, which doubled as Sue's sewing room was relatively tidy and didn't appear to have been touched during the attack. Sue's bedroom at the end of the hall was similarly neat and there was no blood. Smudges of blood were discovered in the bathroom, specifically in the bathtub. Blood pooled around the plug hole and small bone splinters were found in the crook of the drain. This suggested that the killer had showered after carrying out the murders, with the bone fragments having likely been washed from their knife. The knife itself was nowhere to be found. Small spots of blood were also found on the lid of the washing machine. The killer might have used the machine or at least considered doing so.
他的房间兼作苏的缝纫室，相对整洁，袭击过程中似乎没有被触动。走廊尽头的苏的卧室同样整洁，没有血迹。在浴室里，特别是在浴缸里发现了血迹。血汇集在排水孔周围，排水管的弯头处发现了细小的骨头碎片。这表明凶手在行凶后洗了澡，骨头碎片很可能是从他们的刀上洗下来的。刀本身不见踪影。洗衣机盖上也发现了小血点。凶手可能使用了洗衣机，或者至少考虑过这样做。
The living room revealed further evidence of the killer's attempt to clean themselves up. A small blood-soaked tower lay on the couch. A second blood-soaked tower was found at a playground 300 metres from number 147 on Wellington Street. As DNA testing wasn't available in the late 70s, it couldn't be determined whether any of the blood belonged to the killer. Sue's blood type was Type O and Sue'sans was Type A, both common blood groups. Only Type A blood was found in Sue'sans bedroom, the bathroom and on the blood-soaked towers, while only Type O blood was found smeared in the hallway. This either meant that the killer wasn't wounded during the attacks or that he shared a common blood type with one of his victims. However, he did leave one undisputable piece of evidence behind.
客厅揭示了凶手试图清理自己的进一步证据。沙发上放着一条浸满血迹的毛巾。在距离147号300米处的惠灵顿街游乐场发现了第二条浸满血迹的毛巾。由于70年代末没有DNA检测技术，无法确定这些血迹是否属于凶手。苏的血型是O型，苏珊的是A型，都是常见的血型。在苏珊的卧室、浴室和浸满血迹的毛巾上只发现了A型血，而走廊里只发现了O型血。这要么意味着凶手在袭击中没有受伤，要么意味着他与其中一名受害者血型相同。然而，他确实留下了一个无可辩驳的证据。
Seaman was found on Sue'sans Armstrong's body as well as on her bedroom carpet, bedsheets and one of the towers. There were no signs of forced entry into number 147 and when police arrived, both the front and back doors were unlocked. If the women had purposely left the doors unlocked, which they were known to do, the killer might have let himself in uninvited, walked into Sue'sans Armstrong's bedroom and launched an attack. Yet, the top sheet of Sue'sans bed was neatly folded over and a book was facedown on the corner. It appeared as though she'd been reading in bed when her killer entered. If it was a stranger, Sue'sans would have scrambled out of bed in a panic, leaving things in a far more disorderly state than the way they were found. Maybe the killer had knocked on the front door or on Sue'sans window and she had let him inside. Or perhaps she had been expecting a guest and had left the front or back door unlocked so they could let themselves in.
在苏珊·阿姆斯特朗的尸体上，以及她的卧室地毯、床单和其中一条毛巾上发现了精液。147号没有强行进入的迹象，警察到达时，前门和后门都没有锁。如果这两名女性是有意不锁门（她们确实有这个习惯），凶手可能是不请自来，走进苏珊·阿姆斯特朗的卧室并发动了袭击。然而，苏珊床上的床单被整齐地折叠着，一本书面朝下放在角落里。看起来她当时正在床上看书，凶手就进来了。如果是陌生人，苏珊会惊慌失措地从床上爬起来，现场会比发现时的状态混乱得多。也许凶手敲了前门或苏珊的窗户，她让他进来了。或者，也许她一直在等客人，所以没锁前门或后门，好让他们自己进来。
They might have exchanged words or maybe Sue'sans rejected his sexual advances, which had enraged him. Sue'sans family didn't believe she was expecting a visitor. Sue'sans always wore decorative earrings, but at the time of her death she was wearing plain gold sleepers. Her family said she would never wear sleepers if she was expecting male company. Sue was likely in the backyard, kitchen, or possibly doing some laundry at the time, which would explain why she hadn't heard the attack right away. When she realized what was going on, she likely confronted the assailant, who turned his fury to her. Sue had been stabbed almost twice as many times as Suzanne. There were wounds all over her body, including on her buttocks and the back of her thighs.
他们可能发生了口角，或者苏珊拒绝了他的性要求，这激怒了他。苏珊的家人不相信她在等客人。苏珊总是戴着装饰性的耳环，但在她去世时，她戴着普通的金圈耳环。她的家人说，如果她在等男性客人，她绝不会戴这种圈耳环。苏当时很可能在后院、厨房，或者可能在洗衣服，这解释了为什么她没有立即听到袭击声。当她意识到发生了什么时，她很可能与袭击者对峙，袭击者随后将怒火转向了她。苏被刺的次数几乎是苏珊的两倍。她全身都有伤口，包括臀部和大腿后侧。
The killer had continued his attack even after Sue lay incapacitated and face down on the floor. However, the level of overkill Sue endured didn't necessarily mean that she was the killer's main target. The fact that Sue hadn't been sexually assaulted, whereas Suzanne had, indicated that Suzanne was most likely the intended victim. Sue might have been killed in such a vicious way because she took the perpetrator by surprise and he wanted to ensure there were no witnesses. The question remained, who would want to hurt these two young women and why? When investigators initially examined Sue Bartlett's bedroom, nothing appeared noticeably out of place. However, upon closer inspection, they realized something wasn't quite right. Sue's bed sat directly under a window which looked out to the side laneway.
即使在苏倒地不起、脸朝下躺着之后，凶手仍继续行凶。然而，苏所遭受的过度杀戮并不一定意味着她是凶手的主要目标。苏没有受到性侵犯，而苏珊受到了，这表明苏珊很可能是预定的受害者。苏可能以如此残忍的方式被杀，是因为她让袭击者感到意外，而他想确保没有目击者。问题依然存在：谁会想要伤害这两名年轻女性，为什么？当调查人员最初检查苏·巴特利特的卧室时，没有什么明显不对劲的地方。然而，仔细检查后，他们意识到有些不对劲。苏的床直接放在一扇窗户下，窗户可以看到侧巷。
The blind on the window had fallen away at the corner and underneath was a dirty shoe print on Sue's bedspread. After news of the murders hit the press, a tobacco salesman named Colin Fowler, not his real name, showed up at the police station claiming he was the one who left the shoe print. Colin explained that on Tuesday, January 11, he was growing worried about the fact he hadn't heard from Sue in a couple of days. The two had met the previous week and had a date planned for Wednesday evening. Colin had been trying to call Sue to confirm the details, but nobody was answering the phone. He wondered if she might have given him the wrong number by mistake. Colin liked Sue and was eager for their date to go ahead.
窗户上的百叶窗在角落处掉落了，下面是苏的床罩上的一个脏鞋印。谋杀案的消息见报后，一名叫科林·福勒（化名）的烟草推销员出现在警察局，声称那个鞋印是他留下的。科林解释说，1月11日星期二，他因为几天没收到苏的消息而感到担忧。两人上周见过面，并计划在周三晚上约会。科林一直试图打电话给苏确认细节，但没人接电话。他怀疑自己是不是记错了号码。科林喜欢苏，很想让他们的约会如期进行。
On Tuesday night, he had a few too many drinks and decided to stop by Easy Street. Colin was familiar with the house, having spent the night there. He headed down the side laneway and knocked on Sue's bedroom window. There was no reply. Not thinking straight on account of being inebriated, Colin decided to climb in through the window and check Sue's phone to make sure he had been calling the right number. As he clambered through, he knocked the window blind off in the process before leaving his dirty shoe print on Sue's bed.
周二晚上，他喝多了，决定顺路去Easy街看看。科林对这所房子很熟悉，因为他曾在那里过夜。他沿着侧巷走去，敲了苏卧室的窗户。没有回应。由于喝醉了，头脑不清醒，科林决定从窗户爬进去，检查苏的电话，确认自己是否拨打了正确的号码。当他爬进去时，他不小心弄掉了百叶窗，并在苏的床上留下了脏鞋印。
Colin crept up the dark hallway and into the living room. The light was on in the kitchen, so he managed to find the phone which had its number displayed on the dial. It confirmed that he'd been calling the right number. So where was Sue? Colin didn't poke around any further. He was keen to get in and out as quickly as possible, so he hastily left the house the same way he'd entered.
科林蹑手蹑脚地穿过黑暗的走廊进入客厅。厨房里亮着灯，所以他设法找到了电话，电话拨号盘上显示着号码。这证实了他拨打的号码是正确的。那么苏在哪里呢？科林没有再四处打探。他急于尽快离开，所以他匆忙地沿着进来的路离开了房子。
Had he looked down the hallway, he would have noticed Sue's bloodied body lying by the front door. Whether it was the fold of the alcohol or the darkness, Colin claimed he never saw Sue's body. Colin found out about the murders after a friend read about them in a newspaper and recognized Sue's photo. He was horrified to discover he'd been in the house while the two women lay undiscovered. He also realized this didn't look good for him. Enlisting the help of a lawyer, Colin immediately went to the police station to clear his name. Investigators weren't convinced. It seemed highly unlikely that Colin could have stood mere metres away from Sue's body and not seen her,
如果他往走廊看一眼，他就会注意到苏血迹斑斑的尸体躺在大门边。无论是酒精的作用还是黑暗的原因，科林声称他从未看到苏的尸体。科林是在一位朋友在报纸上读到谋杀案并认出苏的照片后才得知此事的。他惊恐地发现，当这两名女性躺在屋里未被发现时，他竟然就在屋里。他也意识到这对他的形象不利。在律师的帮助下，科林立即前往警察局洗清自己的嫌疑。调查人员并不相信。科林站在离苏的尸体仅几米远的地方却没看到她，这似乎极不可能，
nor heard Suzanne's son's weak cries for attention. Colin had also been one of the last people to spend time at 147 Easy Street, having slept over with Sue two nights prior. Witnesses recalled seeing his car parked out the front at the time. It was a white Mercedes and hard to miss. Was it possible that Colin had sneaked in through the window, killed both women, washed himself clean, then quickly fled the area? His story about checking Sue's phone number could be a ruse used to explain away his footprint at the scene. According to Colin, a friend had accompanied him on his late-night trek to Easy Street. He stood watch in the laneway as Colin broke into Sue's bedroom.
也没听到苏珊儿子的微弱哭声。科林也是最后在Easy街147号待过的人之一，两天前他还在苏那里过夜。目击者回忆说，当时看到他的车停在前面。那是一辆白色的奔驰，很难错过。有没有可能科林从窗户溜进去，杀死了两名女性，洗干净自己，然后迅速逃离了现场？他关于检查苏电话号码的故事可能是一个用来解释他在现场留下脚印的借口。据科林说，一个朋友陪他深夜去了Easy街。当科林闯入苏的卧室时，他在巷子里放哨。
The friend vouched for Colin's entire story, confirming he was in and out of the house in a matter of minutes, and made no mention of seeing anything out of the ordinary inside. Yet, Colin Fowler wasn't the only person prowling around 147 Easy Street. In the kitchen, investigators discovered an envelope tucked under an ashtray on a table. A phone number was written on the back of it, along with the message to ring now. It was an urgent request, as the word now was capitalized and had been followed up with an exclamation mark. Alongside the phone number was the name Barry Woodard. 31-year-old Barry Woodard was thrilled when he was set up on a blind date with Suzanne Armstrong late in 1976.
那个朋友为科林的整个故事作了担保，证实他在几分钟内就进出了房子，并且没有提到在里面看到任何异常。然而，科林·福勒并不是唯一在Easy街147号徘徊的人。在厨房里，调查人员发现了一个塞在桌上烟灰缸下的信封。背面写着一个电话号码，还有“现在打”的信息。这是一个紧急请求，因为“现在”这个词是大写的，后面还跟着一个感叹号。电话号码旁边是巴里·伍达德的名字。31岁的巴里·伍达德在1976年底被安排与苏珊·阿姆斯特朗相亲时非常兴奋。
They were introduced by Suzanne's sister, who was going out with Barry's brother. Barry and Suzanne got along great. Although they had only been on three dates, Barry could feel himself falling for Suzanne, and he even began considering marriage. On Sunday, January 9, 1977, Suzanne joined Barry for dinner at his sister's house in the suburb of Northcote, where Barry was staying at the time. He worked as a roving shearer, which meant he was constantly moving around, but he typically stayed at his sister's house on weekends. After dinner, he dropped Suzanne back at Easy Street. Barry was invited inside for coffee, and Suzanne suggested he stay the night. But as he was expecting a call regarding a shearing job early in the morning, Barry declined the offer.
他们是由苏珊的妹妹介绍认识的，她当时正在和巴里的弟弟约会。巴里和苏珊相处得很好。虽然他们只约会了三次，但巴里能感觉到自己爱上了苏珊，甚至开始考虑结婚。1977年1月9日星期日，苏珊和巴里一起在巴里当时居住的北科特郊区的他妹妹家吃了晚饭。他是一名流动剪羊毛工，这意味着他经常四处奔波，但周末通常住在妹妹家。晚饭后，他把苏珊送回了Easy街。巴里被邀请进去喝咖啡，苏珊建议他留宿。但由于他预计第二天一早会接到关于剪羊毛工作的电话，巴里拒绝了。
He drove back to Northcote at around midnight. The next morning, Barry didn't get the job call he was expecting. He called Suzanne to let her know that he wouldn't be working after all, but nobody answered the phone. The two had already discussed another dinner date for Tuesday evening, and Barry was keen to lock in the details. He kept calling Suzanne, but the phone continued to ring out. By Tuesday evening, he still hadn't heard from Suzanne to confirm what time she wanted to be picked up that night. Barry tried calling her several more times, but with no success. By Wednesday afternoon, Barry was really starting to worry.
他在午夜左右开车回到了北科特。第二天早上，巴里没有接到他预期的工作电话。他打电话给苏珊，告诉她他最终不会去工作了，但没人接电话。两人已经讨论过周二晚上再约一次晚餐，巴里很想确定细节。他不断给苏珊打电话，但电话一直响个不停。到了周二晚上，他仍然没有收到苏珊的消息来确认那天晚上几点去接她。巴里又试着打了好几次电话，但都没有成功。到了周三下午，巴里真的开始担心了。
Although he hadn't known Suzanne long, it simply wasn't like her to flake on their plans without being in touch. He shared his concerns with his brother, and the two decided to drop by Easy Street to make sure everything was okay. They arrived at around 8.30pm on Wednesday. It didn't look like anyone was home. No lights were on inside, and there was a note pinned to the front door. The two brothers walked down the side laneway and threw the rear gate into the backyard. A light was on in the kitchen, and the back door was slightly ajar. Barry knocked on the door and yelled out Suzanne's name.
虽然他认识苏珊不久，但她绝不是那种不联系就爽约的人。他向弟弟表达了自己的担忧，两人决定顺路去Easy街看看是否一切正常。他们于周三晚上8点30分左右到达。看起来家里没人。屋里没开灯，前门上贴着一张字条。两兄弟沿着侧巷走，穿过后门进入后院。厨房里亮着灯，后门微微敞开。巴里敲了敲门，大声喊着苏珊的名字。
There was no reply. He figured she couldn't be too far away, but the thought of entering the house without permission made Barry feel uneasy. The brothers decided they'd just duck inside quickly to leave Suzanne a note. They went into the kitchen, scribbled Barry's number down on the back of an envelope, and left it on the table. Barry's brother suggested they check the bedrooms, but Barry didn't feel comfortable going any further, so they left via the back door and returned to their sister's house. Had they headed down the hallway, they would have encountered the dead bodies of both women. On Thursday morning, Barry called 147 Easy Street again. Finally, someone picked up the phone.
没有回应。他想她应该离得不远，但未经允许进入房子的想法让巴里感到不安。两兄弟决定进去快速留下一张字条给苏珊。他们走进厨房，在信封背面潦草地写下巴里的号码，放在桌子上。巴里的弟弟建议他们检查一下卧室，但巴里觉得再深入进去不舒服，所以他们从后门离开，回到了他妹妹家。如果他们往走廊走，就会遇到两名女性的尸体。周四早上，巴里再次拨打了Easy街147号的电话。终于，有人接了电话。
It was a homicide detective who broke the news about the murders. Barry was in shock. When he identified himself, the detective recognized his name from the envelope on the kitchen table. He immediately sent authorities to Barry's sister's house to bring him to the police station for questioning. Barry insisted he had nothing to hide. He hadn't noticed anything unusual at 147 Easy Street when he visited on Wednesday night, nor had he heard Gregory crying. Barry said that if he had, he would have gone down the hallway to see if everything was all right. As for the night of the murders, Barry told police he and his brother went drinking at a pub before returning to their sister's home where they were both staying.
那是一位凶杀案侦探，他告知了谋杀案的消息。巴里惊呆了。当他自报姓名时，侦探从厨房桌上的信封上认出了他的名字。他立即派人前往巴里妹妹家，将他带到警察局接受讯问。巴里坚称自己没什么可隐瞒的。他周三晚上去的时候，并没有注意到Easy街147号有什么异常，也没有听到格雷戈里哭。巴里说，如果他听到了，他会沿着走廊去看看是否一切正常。至于谋杀案发生的当晚，巴里告诉警察，他和弟弟去酒吧喝酒，然后回到他们住的妹妹家。
They ate a late dinner, had some more drinks, and watched television. Barry said he went to bed around midnight and didn't get up until early the next morning. His sister verified this alibi. She had stayed up until 2am and didn't recall seeing Barry leave the house at any point. When she got up at 6.30am, she brought Barry a cup of coffee. There was nothing unusual about his appearance or demeanour. Barry was heartbroken by the news of Suzanne's death. He declared his love for her via the press, saying he was very fond of Suzanne's son and would happily adopt him.
他们吃了顿晚饭，又喝了点酒，看了电视。巴里说他在午夜左右上床睡觉，直到第二天一早才起床。他的妹妹证实了这个不在场证明。她一直待到凌晨2点，不记得看到巴里在任何时候离开过房子。当她在早上6点30分起床时，她给巴里端了一杯咖啡。他的外表和举止没有任何异常。巴里对苏珊去世的消息感到心碎。他通过媒体表达了对她的爱，说他非常喜欢苏珊的儿子，并愿意收养他。
Investigators weren't so sure. Barry's own admissions had placed him at the scene of the crime before the bodies were discovered and it seemed a bit strange that he wouldn't have checked the entire house if he was that worried about Suzanne. They also couldn't rule out the possibility that he had sneaked out of his sister's house during the night without anyone noticing. Given he was dating Suzanne at the time of the murders, he was an obvious suspect. Investigators weren't entirely sure what to make of the situation. While it was highly unusual that two men who were romantically involved with the victims had entered the crime scene, it didn't mean either of them were guilty. As police began questioning friends and associates of the two women, they learned that Barry Woodard wasn't the only man that Suzanne Armstrong had recently been involved with. Described as, quote, very attractive with the personality to match, Suzanne had several admirers.
调查人员并不确定。巴里自己的供述将他置于尸体被发现前的犯罪现场，如果他真的那么担心苏珊，没有检查整个房子似乎有点奇怪。他们也不能排除他在夜间溜出妹妹家而无人察觉的可能性。鉴于他在谋杀案发生时正在和苏珊约会，他是一个明显的嫌疑人。调查人员并不完全确定该如何处理这种情况。虽然两名与受害者有浪漫关系的男子进入犯罪现场是非常不寻常的，但这并不意味着他们中任何一人有罪。当警察开始询问这两名女性的朋友和同事时，他们得知巴里·伍达德并不是苏珊·阿姆斯特朗最近交往过的唯一男性。苏珊被描述为“非常迷人，性格也很好”，有几个仰慕者。
Some friends described her as too trusting and said she'd recently been spending time with some questionable people. On occasion, she had invited them to Easy Street, which had made Sue feel uncomfortable. One such person was a former police officer who had been kicked off the force for sexually assaulting female motorists while on the job. He had attended a housewarming party the two Sues had thrown just weeks before the murders and some guests recalled he'd been watching Suzanne very closely. Investigators questioned the former officer, who gave contradictory statements when asked about his whereabouts on the week of the murders. Something about his behaviour seemed off. Then there was an ex-boyfriend that Suzanne's family believed could be involved. A violent alcoholic with a criminal record, this man was reportedly drinking in a Collingwood pub on the night of the murders, just blocks away from Easy Street.
一些朋友形容她太容易相信别人，并说她最近一直在和一些可疑的人交往。有时，她会邀请他们去Easy街，这让苏感到不舒服。其中一个人是一名被开除的前警官，他因在职期间性侵女司机而被开除。他参加了两个“苏”在谋杀案发生前几周举办的乔迁派对，一些客人回忆说他一直在非常密切地注视着苏珊。调查人员询问了这名前警官，他在被问及谋杀案发生当周的行踪时给出了相互矛盾的陈述。他的行为有些不对劲。还有一个苏珊家人认为可能涉案的前男友。此人是一个有犯罪记录的暴力酒鬼，据报道，在谋杀案发生的当晚，他在科林伍德的一家酒吧喝酒，距离Easy街仅几个街区。
His girlfriend vouched for his whereabouts, saying the two were together the entire night. Working on the theory that Suzanne may have rejected the sexual advances of a former lover or someone she had recently been spending time with, several other men were added to the suspect pool. Investigators also had to consider whether the killer could have been motivated by revenge. Suzanne was a romantic at heart. It was while she was visiting the Greek islands that she met a local fisherman named Manolis. The two fell in love and Suzanne stayed in Greece for a while. She soon became pregnant and she and Manolis decided to get married. Foreign bureaucracy complicated their plans and they ultimately felt it was too much hassle.
他的女朋友为他的行踪作了担保，说两人整晚都在一起。基于苏珊可能拒绝了前情人或她最近一直交往的人的性要求这一理论，其他几名男子被列入了嫌疑人名单。调查人员还必须考虑凶手是否出于报复动机。苏珊内心是个浪漫主义者。正是在访问希腊群岛时，她遇到了一个名叫马诺利斯的当地渔民。两人坠入爱河，苏珊在希腊待了一段时间。她很快怀孕了，她和马诺利斯决定结婚。外国官僚机构使他们的计划变得复杂，他们最终觉得太麻烦了。
After giving birth, Suzanne was homesick for Australia, but Manolis didn't want to leave. Knowing that he wouldn't agree to let her take their baby boy away for good, Suzanne told Manolis she was simply returning to Australia for a visit. When she reached Melbourne with baby Gregory, she sent Manolis a letter saying she wouldn't be coming back to Greece. Manolis was heartbroken. He thought Suzanne was the love of his life and he struggled to come to terms with the abrupt separation. While this could have given Manolis a motive to want to hurt Suzanne, police confirmed he never left Greece. Some speculated whether Manolis might have had ties to the strong Greek community in Collingwood and sent someone to pay Suzanne a vengeful visit on his behalf. But there was no evidence to support this theory.
生下孩子后，苏珊想念澳大利亚，但马诺利斯不想离开。知道他不会同意让她永远带走他们的男婴，苏珊告诉马诺利斯她只是回澳大利亚探亲。当她带着婴儿格雷戈里到达墨尔本时，她给马诺利斯写了一封信，说她不会再回希腊了。马诺利斯心碎了。他认为苏珊是他一生的挚爱，他难以接受这种突然的分离。虽然这可能给了马诺利斯伤害苏珊的动机，但警方证实他从未离开过希腊。一些人猜测马诺利斯是否可能与科林伍德强大的希腊社区有联系，并派人代表他去对苏珊进行报复。但没有证据支持这一理论。
While evidence indicated that the killer targeted Suzanne Armstrong, this couldn't be said with absolute certainty. It was possible that the crime was a random opportunistic attack committed by a dangerous predator. Two pubs were within close walking distance of 147 Easy Street, both of which closed at midnight. This gave a reason for men who didn't necessarily live nearby to be in the area late at night. Police couldn't discount the possibility that someone unknown to the victims had committed the crime in a drunken rage. Detectives got to work at gathering the names of all known sex offenders, both locally and interstate. Witnesses who saw anything out of the ordinary in the early morning hours of Tuesday, January 11 were urged to come forward. Dry cleaners who may have laundered blood-stained clothing were also told to contact the authorities.
虽然证据表明凶手针对的是苏珊·阿姆斯特朗，但这不能绝对肯定。这起犯罪也可能是一个危险的掠食者随机实施的机会性袭击。Easy街147号附近有两家酒吧，都在午夜关门。这给了不一定住在附近的人在深夜出现在该地区的理由。警方不能排除受害者不认识的人在醉酒狂怒中犯罪的可能性。侦探们开始收集所有已知性犯罪者的名单，包括本地和州际的。目击者如果看到1月11日星期二凌晨有任何异常情况，被敦促站出来。可能清洗过血迹斑斑衣物的干洗店也被告知联系当局。
A police spokesperson said, The killer can't have washed off all the blood, someone must have seen him, a friend or a relative probably, or maybe someone in the street, just so long as that someone tells us. This man is sick, very sick, and unless we catch him, he will strike again. Then came a promising discovery. Shortly after the double homicide, a police officer was searching a car in relation to a separate matter. In the boot of the vehicle, he found a leather sheath that held a blood-stained knife. It was 26 centimetres long, with a small curve at the tip of the blade that could have been caused by hitting something solid, like bone. The vehicle's owner strongly denied having anything to do with the Yeezy Street murders.
警方发言人说：“凶手不可能洗掉所有的血迹，一定有人见过他，可能是朋友或亲戚，或者可能是街上的某个人，只要那个人告诉我们。这个人病了，病得很重，除非我们抓住他，否则他会再次行凶。”随后出现了一个有希望的发现。双重谋杀案发生后不久，一名警察在处理另一起案件时搜查了一辆汽车。在车后备箱里，他发现了一个皮鞘，里面装着一把沾满血迹的刀。它长26厘米，刀尖有一个小弯曲，这可能是撞击坚硬物体（如骨头）造成的。车主强烈否认与Easy街谋杀案有任何关系。
He insisted he had found the knife on the platform of the Victoria Park railway station, 450 metres northeast of the murder scene. He'd come across it on Monday, January 10, sometime between 10.20 and 11pm. Although this seemed highly suspicious, the owner of the vehicle was quickly ruled out. Not only did he have an alibi for the night of the murders, others also vouched for his story about finding the knife. Investigators ultimately discounted the knife as the murder weapon, given that it was found only 90 minutes after Sue Bartlett's brother, Martin, left Yeezy Street. It didn't seem possible that the killer could have conducted such a frenzied attack, spent time in the house cleaning himself up, and then made it to Victoria Park station in such a short time frame. Respected journalist Tess Lawrence covered the Armstrong and Bartlett case at the request of police. She attended 147 Yeezy Street when Suzanne and Sue's loved ones were permitted to enter the house to collect their belongings.
他坚持说他在维多利亚公园火车站的站台上发现了这把刀，该站位于谋杀现场东北450米处。他在1月10日星期一晚上10点20分到11点之间的某个时间发现了它。虽然这看起来非常可疑，但车主很快被排除了嫌疑。他不仅有谋杀案当晚的不在场证明，其他人也为他关于发现刀的故事作了担保。调查人员最终排除了这把刀作为凶器的可能性，因为它是苏·巴特利特的哥哥马丁离开Easy街仅90分钟后被发现的。凶手似乎不可能在这么短的时间内进行如此疯狂的袭击，在屋里花时间清理自己，然后到达维多利亚公园车站。受人尊敬的记者苔丝·劳伦斯应警方要求报道了阿姆斯特朗和巴特利特案。当苏珊和苏的亲人获准进入房子收拾遗物时，她去了Easy街147号。
Published in the Herald newspaper, Tess's article detailed the layout of the house and the items within. Shortly after it ran, Tess received a phone call at work from a man whose voice she didn't recognize. He began dissecting the details of her article line by line and criticized Tess for not being very observant. Tess had mentioned there was a record player in the living room, the one Martin Bartlett had stopped by to fix on the Monday night, but she didn't mention the names of any of the records. The caller pointed this out. He then mentioned the name of one record, claiming it was on the turntable at the time. During the early days of the media coverage, it's believed that police intentionally fed journalists several incorrect details, so they'd be able to identify any misinformation or false confessions that might come through. Not only was it falsely reported that Sue Bartlett had also been raped, but a layout of the murder scene published in newspapers purposefully included a few minor discrepancies. When Tess Lawrence's article about the crime was published, she deliberately omitted the name of the record that was on the living room turntable at the time the murders were carried out.
苔丝的文章发表在《先驱报》上，详细描述了房子的布局和里面的物品。文章发表后不久，苔丝在工作中接到了一个男人的电话，她听不出他的声音。他开始逐行剖析她的文章细节，并批评苔丝观察不够仔细。苔丝提到客厅里有一台唱片机，就是马丁·巴特利特周一晚上过来修理的那台，但她没有提到任何唱片的名称。打电话的人指出了这一点。然后他提到了其中一张唱片的名称，声称当时唱片就在转盘上。在媒体报道的早期，据信警方故意向记者提供了一些不正确的信息，以便他们能够识别可能出现的任何错误信息或虚假供词。不仅有虚假报道称苏·巴特利特也遭到了强奸，而且报纸上公布的谋杀现场布局也故意包含了一些细微的差异。当苔丝·劳伦斯关于这起犯罪的文章发表时，她故意省略了谋杀发生时客厅转盘上那张唱片的名称。
Tess was left stunned when the mysterious caller correctly named this record. She scrawled a quick note to a colleague asking to try and have the call traced, while simultaneously trying to keep the caller on the line. He refused to identify himself, but claimed to work at the Victoria Barracks. The caller said he'd phoned back before abruptly ending the call. Tess immediately reported the incident to the police. This was just one of thousands of tip-offs received in the first two weeks of the Armstrong-Bartlett murder investigation. At the time, Victoria's Homicide Squad only had 16 detectives. In the first 21 days of January alone, 11 murders had been committed throughout the state for an average of one murder every second day.
当神秘的来电者准确说出这张唱片的名字时，苔丝惊呆了。她匆忙给同事写了一张便条，要求设法追踪这通电话，同时试图稳住对方。来电者拒绝透露身份，但声称自己在维多利亚军营工作。来电者说完便挂断了电话。苔丝立即向警方报告了此事。这只是阿姆斯特朗-巴特利特谋杀案调查头两周内收到的数千条线索之一。当时，维多利亚州凶杀案调查组只有16名侦探。仅在1月的前21天里，全州就发生了11起谋杀案，平均每两天就有一人遇害。
It was the largest number of murder cases on record since 1955. Resources were stretched incredibly thin. While the Easy Street Murders was one of the most brutal sex crimes in Victoria's history, investigators had several other unsolved cases vying for their attention. The owner of a massage parlor was shot to death outside his home, while another man had been stabbed in the throat with a broken beer bottle. A husband and wife were shot during a home invasion. The woman survived, but the man wasn't so lucky. None of the other murders were thought to be linked to the deaths of Sue and Suzanne, but those critical of the investigation believed the spiking crime meant the Easy Street case wasn't getting the undivided attention it deserved. Surely a case of that nature, which had terrified young women all over the city, should be top priority.
这是自1955年以来记录在案的谋杀案数量最多的一次。警力资源极其匮乏。虽然“易街谋杀案”是维多利亚州历史上最残忍的性犯罪之一，但调查人员还有其他几起悬案需要处理。一家按摩院的老板在家门外被枪杀，另一名男子被碎啤酒瓶刺穿喉咙。一对夫妇在入室抢劫中被枪击，女子幸存，但男子没那么幸运。虽然这些谋杀案被认为与苏和苏珊的死无关，但批评调查的人认为，犯罪率的激增意味着“易街”案件没有得到应有的全力关注。毕竟，这种性质的案件让全城的年轻女性感到恐慌，理应被列为重中之重。
What the press and public didn't know was that investigators had already set their sights on a promising person of interest. 21-year-old crime reporter John Grant worked at the same newspaper as Easy Street resident Alona. Although the two colleagues weren't particularly close, they had gone out together on the night of Monday, January 11. Alona felt sorry for John. He'd been having a tough time lately. There were some rumours circulating about him at work, and he had a difficult home life. They ended up back at 149 Easy Street having drinks and playing pool in Alona's lounge room until the early hours of the morning. By 2am, it was too late for Grant to make his way home, so he decided to sleep on the couch. The next morning, he got a lift to work with Alona. Two days later, Alona went next door, where she discovered the bloodied bodies of Suzanne Armstrong and Susan Bartlett. When John Grant was questioned by police, he maintained he hadn't heard anything next door on the night he slept at Easy Street.
媒体和公众不知道的是，调查人员已经盯上了一位有嫌疑的重点人物。21岁的犯罪记者约翰·格兰特与“易街”居民阿洛娜在同一家报社工作。虽然两位同事关系并不特别亲密，但他们在1月11日星期一晚上曾一起外出。阿洛娜为约翰感到难过，他最近过得很艰难。工作中有关于他的传言，他的家庭生活也很不如意。他们最后回到易街149号，在阿洛娜的客厅里喝酒打台球，一直待到凌晨。凌晨2点时，格兰特回家已经太晚了，于是他决定睡在沙发上。第二天早上，他搭阿洛娜的车去上班。两天后，阿洛娜去隔壁时，发现了苏珊·阿姆斯特朗和苏珊·巴特利特血迹斑斑的尸体。当约翰·格兰特接受警方询问时，他坚称自己在易街过夜的那晚没有听到隔壁有任何动静。
While this wasn't suspicious in and of itself, there was something about John Grant's presence in the neighborhood that immediately raised a red flag. 18 months earlier, a 19-year-old American woman named Julianne Garcia-Salay went missing from the flat she shared with her sister in North Melbourne. On the night she disappeared, Julianne invited three men whom she had recently met over to her flat to discuss the possibility of opening a restaurant. The men claimed that Julianne left at around 10.30pm to make a phone call from a public pay phone and never returned. They eventually got sick of waiting and decided to leave. Police weren't convinced of their story. Not only were several items missing from the flat, including $125 cash and a carving knife, but a blood-soaked towel was also found and a pair of Julianne's underwear was on the floor. Furthermore, one of the men who had visited Julianne that night was a known career criminal named Joseph John Power, who had faced prior murder allegations. One of the other men was John Grant. Grant was the kind of crime reporter who mingled with both police sources and criminal contacts, whatever it took to get a good story.
虽然这本身并不令人怀疑，但约翰·格兰特出现在那个街区的事实确实引起了警方的警觉。18个月前，一名叫朱莉安·加西亚-萨莱的19岁美国女子从她与姐姐在北墨尔本合租的公寓中失踪。失踪当晚，朱莉安邀请了她刚认识的三名男子到公寓讨论开餐厅的可能性。这几名男子声称，朱莉安在晚上10点半左右离开去公用电话亭打电话，之后就再也没回来。他们最终等得不耐烦，决定离开。警方并不相信他们的说辞。公寓里不仅丢失了几件物品，包括125美元现金和一把切肉刀，而且还发现了一条浸透鲜血的毛巾，地板上还有一条朱莉安的内裤。此外，当晚拜访朱莉安的其中一名男子是臭名昭著的职业罪犯约瑟夫·约翰·鲍尔，他曾面临过谋杀指控。另一名男子就是约翰·格兰特。格兰特属于那种为了拿到好新闻，既与警方线人打交道，又与犯罪分子接触的犯罪记者。
His gift of the gab and hard drinking ways meant he could work both sides, but this time his close connections with the criminal world had left him in hot water. Grant claimed he had left Julianne's house before the other two men. He remembered it specifically because he'd called his editor and asked for permission to take a taxi home that could be reimbursed as a work expense. Police didn't necessarily think that Grant was involved with Julianne's disappearance. They did, however, suspect that Joseph John Power had something to do with it. The problem was that Power had recently made allegations of misconduct against Victoria Police after they accused him of another murder and an inquiry into his complaint was currently underway. Because of this, police were wary of investigating him for Julianne's disappearance and they didn't pursue the matter any further. John Grant claimed it was an unfortunate coincidence that he was with Julianne on the night she disappeared and next door to Suzanne Armstrong and Sue Bartlett on the night they were killed. Police interrogated him for an entire day, but he staunchly maintained his innocence. Alona said she didn't hear Grant get up or leave the house after he went to bed.
他能言善辩且嗜酒如命，这意味着他能游走于黑白两道，但这一次，他与犯罪世界的密切联系让他陷入了困境。格兰特声称他在另外两名男子之前就离开了朱莉安的家。他记得很清楚，因为他曾打电话给编辑，请求报销打车回家的费用作为工作开支。警方并不一定认为格兰特与朱莉安的失踪有关。然而，他们确实怀疑约瑟夫·约翰·鲍尔与此事有关。问题在于，鲍尔最近在被警方指控犯下另一起谋杀案后，对维多利亚警方提出了不当行为指控，针对他投诉的调查正在进行中。因此，警方对调查他是否涉及朱莉安的失踪持谨慎态度，没有进一步追究此事。约翰·格兰特声称，他与朱莉安失踪当晚在一起，又与苏珊·阿姆斯特朗和苏·巴特利特遇害当晚住在隔壁，这纯属不幸的巧合。警方审讯了他整整一天，但他坚决维护自己的清白。阿洛娜说，她没有听到格兰特在睡觉后起床或离开房子的声音。
Her flatmate Janet was reading in bed until 4am and didn't hear anything either. When Alona woke up the next morning, Grant had already showered and was wearing the same clothes as the night before. They were clean and dry with no visible stains. There was nothing unusual about his behaviour that day or in the days following. Although there was no evidence to suggest that John Grant was involved with the Easy Street murders in any way, that didn't stop the speculation. After all, what were the chances that one crime reporter could be in the wrong place at the wrong time on two separate occasions? Police also believed the Easy Street killer had knowledge of forensic procedures which Grant did given his line of work. Furthermore, both the Easy Street crime scene and Julianne Garcia-Selaise flat shared a similarity. The presence of a blood-soaked towel and a pair of women's underwear left on the floor. Given Grant's association with the Joseph John Power, some wondered whether it was possible that Power had followed Grant to Easy Street on January 11 for an unknown reason.
她的室友珍妮特在床上看书直到凌晨4点，也没有听到任何声音。第二天早上阿洛娜醒来时，格兰特已经洗过澡，穿着和前一天晚上一样的衣服。衣服干净干燥，没有明显的污渍。那天以及随后的几天里，他的行为没有任何异常。虽然没有证据表明约翰·格兰特以任何方式参与了易街谋杀案，但这并没有阻止人们的猜测。毕竟，一个犯罪记者在两个不同的场合出现在错误的时间和错误的地点，这种概率有多大？警方还认为，易街的凶手具备法医知识，而格兰特凭借他的职业背景确实具备这些知识。此外，易街犯罪现场和朱莉安·加西亚-萨莱的公寓有一个共同点：地板上都留有一条浸透鲜血的毛巾和一条女性内裤。考虑到格兰特与约瑟夫·约翰·鲍尔的关系，一些人怀疑鲍尔是否可能出于某种未知原因在1月11日跟踪格兰特到了易街。
Maybe he'd caught a glimpse of Suzanne Armstrong in her front bedroom and acted on impulse. Power was known to be a violent, dangerous criminal and he was physically capable of overpowering two unsuspecting women. It was a bit of a far-fetched theory, but every possibility had to be considered now that the investigation wasn't shaping up to be as straightforward as initially anticipated. The major hindrance was that nobody had witnessed anything suspicious around 147 Easy Street on the night of the murders. Or had they? Gladys Coventry was a veteran of Easy Street, having lived in number 145 since 1963. According to the book Murder on Easy Street by Helen Thomas, the elderly Gladys made a habit of sitting in her kitchen late on summer nights to take advantage of the cool evening breeze. Tuesday, January 11, 1977, was no different. But as Gladys enjoyed the fresh air on that hot night, she peered outside and noticed something at number 147.
也许他瞥见了前卧室里的苏珊·阿姆斯特朗，便一时冲动行事。鲍尔是一个众所周知的暴力、危险的罪犯，他有能力制服两名毫无防备的女性。这个理论虽然有些牵强，但既然调查不像最初预期的那样简单，每一种可能性都必须考虑。主要的障碍是，在谋杀案发生的当晚，没有人看到易街147号附近有任何可疑情况。或者说，真的没有人看到吗？格拉迪斯·考文垂是易街的老住户，自1963年以来一直住在145号。据海伦·托马斯的《易街谋杀案》一书所述，年迈的格拉迪斯习惯在夏夜深夜坐在厨房里，享受凉爽的晚风。1977年1月11日星期二也不例外。但当格拉迪斯在那个炎热的夜晚享受新鲜空气时，她向外望去，注意到了147号的一些情况。
Her home was on the opposite side of the laneway to Sue and Suzanne's and from her vantage point, Gladys could see directly into their kitchen. There was a man standing at the sink, washing his hands repeatedly. It also looked like he was scrubbing on a piece of clothing. Gladys had never seen the man before, or if she had, she didn't recognise him. She didn't think anything of it. After all, her neighbours often had visitors, and from the casual, unhurried way the man moved about the house, nothing raised any alarm. It was only when Gladys heard about the murders several days later that she was reminded of the sighting. She approached a homicide detective to report what she had seen, but he didn't seem interested. At the time, the homicide squad had a reputation for being arrogant, and it wasn't until the case started to go cold that they realised they might have been too quick to dismiss Gladys' sighting. Detectives approached the elderly woman again, but she was offended that they didn't take her report seriously the first time, and she no longer wanted to speak to them.
她的家在苏和苏珊家巷子的对面，从她的位置可以直接看到她们的厨房。有一个男人站在水槽边，反复洗手。看起来他还在用力搓洗一件衣服。格拉迪斯以前从未见过这个男人，或者即使见过，她也不认识。她没多想。毕竟，邻居们经常有访客，而且从那个男人在屋里随意、不慌不忙的举动来看，没有任何令人警觉的地方。直到几天后格拉迪斯听说谋杀案时，她才想起这次目击。她找到一名凶杀案侦探报告了她所看到的情况，但他似乎并不感兴趣。当时，凶杀案调查组以傲慢著称，直到案件开始陷入僵局，他们才意识到自己可能太快忽略了格拉迪斯的目击证词。侦探们再次找到这位老妇人，但她对他们第一次没有认真对待她的报告感到不满，不再愿意与他们交谈。
Detectives were so interested in the sighting that they even sent a doctor to Gladys' house under the guise that he was performing a welfare check, in the hopes he could get her to talk. But there was no fooling Gladys, who quickly sensed that he was with the police. The detectives realised that they had missed their chance to get a description of the man Gladys claims to have seen in the kitchen of 147, but instead of persevering, they accepted it and moved on. Had they taken Gladys' Coventry's sighting seriously from the start, they may have been able to get a physical description of the killer and an identity kit could have been drawn. But she wasn't the only neighbour who was overlooked by the police. 21-year-old Peter Sellers lived with his family at 139 Easy Street. On the night of Monday, January 11, he had a friend named Ray stay over while the rest of his family were travelling interstate. According to the book Murder on Easy Street, at around 2.30am both Peter and Ray thought they heard a front door slamming.
侦探们对这次目击非常感兴趣，甚至派了一名医生以进行福利检查为幌子去格拉迪斯家，希望他能让她开口。但格拉迪斯并没有被骗，她很快感觉到他是警察派来的。侦探们意识到他们错过了获取格拉迪斯声称在147号厨房看到的那个男人的描述的机会，但他们没有坚持，而是接受了现实并继续前进。如果他们从一开始就认真对待格拉迪斯·考文垂的目击证词，他们或许能得到凶手的体貌特征并绘制出身份拼图。但她并不是唯一被警方忽视的邻居。21岁的彼得·塞勒斯和家人住在易街139号。1月11日星期一晚上，他的家人都在州外旅行，他有一个叫雷的朋友留宿。据《易街谋杀案》一书所述，凌晨2点半左右，彼得和雷都以为他们听到了前门关上的声音。
Moments later, they heard what sounded like two car door slamming before the car quickly took off. When police doorknocked the area once the murders were discovered, Peter wasn't home. However, his mother was there and she told them that her son had information that might be of interest. Police took a note of his name, but never returned to ask Peter what he had seen. Peter just assumed they weren't interested, so he did an attempt to follow it up. The failure to interview key witnesses was just one problem in a long list of failures in the investigation. One of the overriding issues was that the case was overseen purely by the State Homicide Squad, and Collingwood's criminal investigation branch was never brought in to assist.
片刻之后，他们听到了像是两扇车门关上的声音，随后汽车迅速驶离。当谋杀案被发现后，警方对该地区进行了挨家挨户的走访，彼得当时不在家。然而，他的母亲在家，她告诉警察，她的儿子可能有他们感兴趣的信息。警方记下了他的名字，但从未回来询问彼得看到了什么。彼得只是认为他们不感兴趣，所以也没有尝试跟进。未能采访关键证人只是调查中一长串失败中的一个问题。一个主要的问题是，该案完全由州凶杀案调查组负责，科林伍德的刑事调查部门从未被邀请协助。
Had a local police been involved, their specialised knowledge of the area might have led to more possible persons of interest. It didn't help that days had already passed before the crime scene was discovered. This gave the perpetrator plenty of time to dispose of evidence or flee Melbourne. Secondly, although the crime scene was secured as soon as officers descended on the property, things were done differently in the 70s. Police were free to move through the crime scene without wearing any protective clothing. One officer had even washed his hands in the bathroom sink. Failure to maintain the integrity of the crime scene meant crucial evidence might have been missed.
如果当地警方参与其中，他们对该地区的专业知识可能会带来更多可能的嫌疑人。在犯罪现场被发现之前，已经过去了几天，这对调查毫无帮助。这给了肇事者充足的时间来销毁证据或逃离墨尔本。其次，虽然警察一到达现场就封锁了犯罪现场，但在70年代，处理方式有所不同。警察可以随意穿过犯罪现场，而无需穿戴任何防护服。一名警官甚至在浴室的水槽里洗了手。未能保持犯罪现场的完整性意味着关键证据可能已被遗漏。
Complicating matters further was the fact that several detectives seemed convinced they already had their killer within sights. Many believed that John Grant's connection was too coincidental, and it would be a matter of time before evidence linked him to the crime. Others had the same feelings about Barry Woodard, the man Suzanne was dating at the time of her death. This tunnel vision meant that other persons of interest were potentially overlooked. During the short amount of time that Sue Bartlett and Suzanne Armstrong were living on Easy Street, major construction was taking place in the area. Not only was nearby Hoddle Street being widened in conjunction with the New Freeway,
更复杂的是，几名侦探似乎确信他们已经锁定了凶手。许多人认为约翰·格兰特的联系过于巧合，证据迟早会将他与犯罪联系起来。其他人对巴里·伍达德也有同样的感觉，他是苏珊遇害时正在交往的男子。这种隧道视野意味着其他嫌疑人可能被忽视了。在苏·巴特利特和苏珊·阿姆斯特朗住在易街的短时间内，该地区正在进行大规模施工。不仅附近的霍德尔街正在与新高速公路一起拓宽，
but a new community health centre was being built right behind the women's home. Construction workers and other tradies were in and out of the site constantly. Was it possible that one of them had glimpsed into the backyard of 147 Easy Street and caught sight of Sue or Suzanne lounging in their backyard? Perhaps they'd taken an unhealthy interest in one or both of the women and returned to the property after dark. Similarly, concreting work had only recently been done outside of number 147. Could one of these workers have peered in through the front window, taken note of Suzanne and returned to approach her at the property later?
而且就在她们家后面正在建造一个新的社区卫生中心。建筑工人和承包商不断进出工地。有没有可能其中一人瞥见了易街147号的后院，看到了苏或苏珊在后院休息？也许他们对其中一人或两人产生了不健康的兴趣，并在天黑后回到了该处。同样，147号外最近才完成了混凝土浇筑工作。会不会是其中一名工人透过前窗窥视，注意到了苏，并随后回到该处接近她？
Many of these workers were employed short-term and moved around often, so with police chasing other avenues in the early days of the investigation, it would have been easy for any of them to fall through the cracks. On top of the lackluster investigation, the Armstrong and Bartlett families weren't happy with how they were treated by the authorities. They were constantly chasing updates themselves rather than being kept in the loop with how things were progressing. Suzanne's family was never even interviewed by police.
这些工人大多是短期受雇，经常变动，所以当警方在调查初期追查其他线索时，他们中的任何一个人都很容易成为漏网之鱼。除了调查不力之外，阿姆斯特朗和巴特利特家族对当局对待他们的方式也不满意。他们一直在自己追问最新进展，而不是被告知事情的进展情况。苏珊的家人甚至从未接受过警方的采访。
They had to make their own appointment to go down to the station and provide information. By July, six months had passed and police were no closer to making an arrest. An inquest into the murders was held at the Melbourne Coroners Court, but no new evidence was presented. The coroner concluded that Suzanne Armstrong and Suzanne Bartlett had been brutally killed by an unknown person or persons and shared no light on who that person might be. Suzanne's sister Gail was given custody of young Gregory,
他们不得不自己预约去警察局提供信息。到了7月，六个月过去了，警方在逮捕嫌疑人方面毫无进展。墨尔本验尸官法庭对谋杀案进行了调查，但没有提出任何新证据。验尸官得出结论，苏珊·阿姆斯特朗和苏珊·巴特利特被一名或多名身份不明的人残忍杀害，但没有说明那个人可能是谁。苏珊的姐姐盖尔获得了小格雷戈里的监护权，
and in December, her family applied for victims of crime compensation on Gregory's behalf. This was a standard payment of up to $5,000 issued by the Victorian Crimes Compensation Tribunal for dependents of victims who were injured or murdered in a crime. In another blow to the Armstrong family, the tribunal rejected the application on the basis that Gregory was legally considered an illegitimate child because Suzanne hadn't been married to his father.
12月，她的家人代表格雷戈里申请了犯罪受害者赔偿。这是维多利亚州犯罪赔偿法庭为在犯罪中受伤或被谋杀的受害者的家属发放的最高5000美元的标准赔偿金。对阿姆斯特朗家族的又一次打击是，法庭驳回了申请，理由是格雷戈里在法律上被视为非婚生子女，因为苏珊没有与他的父亲结婚。
When words spread about the rejection, the people of Australia were outraged. They rallied behind Gregory with the Victorian Premier announcing he'd make sure Gregory received compensation even if he had to change the laws to do it. The following year, the law was updated and Gregory received $5,000 compensation paid into a trust that he could access on his 18th birthday. The one-year anniversary of the murders passed
当拒绝赔偿的消息传开后，澳大利亚人民感到愤怒。他们支持格雷戈里，维多利亚州州长宣布，即使必须修改法律，他也会确保格雷戈里获得赔偿。第二年，法律进行了更新，格雷戈里获得了5000美元的赔偿金，存入了一个信托基金，他可以在18岁生日时支取。谋杀案一周年纪念日过去了，
with no breakthroughs in the case, despite a $50,000 reward for information being announced. The public and investigators alike found it difficult to believe that the perpetrator continued to go undetected. Surely there must have been something in their behaviour after the crime that tipped somebody off. Perhaps this person had been a heavy drinker who avoided alcohol abruptly following the crime.
案件仍无突破，尽管已宣布悬赏5万美元征集线索。公众和调查人员都难以相信肇事者至今仍未被发现。肯定有什么行为在犯罪后引起了别人的注意。也许这个人曾经是个酒鬼，但在犯罪后突然戒酒了。
Maybe their mental health had taken a sudden downhill turn. It was also hard to believe that someone would commit a crime so brutal and then never re-offend. Suzanne's sister Gail told the media, We'll never really get over this until the fellow is caught. You walk around not knowing who did the murder. It could be the bloke next door. One week later, the Armstrong family were again devastated
也许他们的心理健康状况突然恶化了。也很难相信有人会犯下如此残忍的罪行，然后就再也没有重犯。苏珊的姐姐盖尔告诉媒体：“除非抓住那个家伙，否则我们永远无法真正走出来。你走在街上，不知道是谁杀了人。那个人可能是隔壁的邻居。”一周后，阿姆斯特朗家族再次遭受重创，
when Suzanne's father died from severe burns he had recently sustained from battling a bushfire. His was yet another life tragically lost within the Armstrong and Bartlett families in the aftermath of Suzanne's and Sue's murders. Sue's father had a fatal heart attack upon learning that his daughter had been killed. The next day, one of Sue's aunts also had a heart attack and passed away.
苏珊的父亲因在扑灭丛林大火时遭受严重烧伤而去世。在苏珊和苏遇害后，阿姆斯特朗和巴特利特家族又失去了一条宝贵的生命。苏的父亲在得知女儿遇害后心脏病发作身亡。第二天，苏的一位阿姨也因心脏病发作去世。
Investigators kept an eye out for similar crimes that could potentially be linked but Easy Street remained in a league of its own. Some thought the killer might have already passed away perhaps by suicide or had been jailed for an unrelated offense. With no new information and other cases demanding attention the case went cold.
调查人员密切关注可能相关的类似犯罪，但易街案件依然是独一无二的。有些人认为凶手可能已经去世，也许是自杀，或者因无关的罪行被监禁。由于没有新信息，其他案件也需要关注，该案最终陷入了僵局。
Cursed by its reputation as the murder house No. 147 Easy Street remained empty for six years as still and silent as the investigation itself. The house eventually sold at a discounted price and the new owner renovated it extensively tearing out the old wooden floorboards. Decades after the double homicide, the case was reopened. The new detectives casting their eyes on it for the first time
由于“谋杀屋”的名声，易街147号空置了六年，像调查本身一样沉寂。房子最终以折扣价售出，新主人进行了大规模翻修，拆除了旧木地板。双重谋杀案发生几十年后，案件重新开启。新侦探们第一次审视这些资料时，
were expecting to have boxes of information to sift through. However, when they asked for the documents all they were given was a skinny manila folder containing a few flimsy statements. By the late 90s, forensic technology had improved dramatically and cold cases were starting to be solved using DNA. Victoria police were hopeful these advances would reveal the identity of the Easy Street killer once and for all. There were still eight key suspects on their list
本以为会有成箱的信息需要梳理。然而，当他们索要文件时，只得到一个薄薄的马尼拉文件夹，里面装着几份单薄的陈述。到了90年代末，法医技术有了显著提高，悬案开始利用DNA技术解决。维多利亚警方希望这些进展能一劳永逸地揭开易街凶手的身份。名单上仍有八名主要嫌疑人，
including Barry Woodard and John Grant and each one of them agreed to provide a blood sample. DNA from their blood was tested against the semen of the killer. None were a match. This outcome was a major blow. For years investigators and the Armstrong and Bartlett police had held out hope that DNA would be the clue that finally held the answers. New leads had long since dried up
包括巴里·伍达德和约翰·格兰特，他们每人都同意提供血液样本。他们血液中的DNA与凶手的精液进行了比对。没有一个是匹配的。这一结果是一个重大打击。多年来，调查人员和阿姆斯特朗及巴特利特家族一直寄希望于DNA能成为最终揭开谜底的线索。新的线索早已枯竭，
and now that the physical evidence eliminated the major persons of interest it seemed increasingly unlikely that the case would ever be solved. Then in September 1999 a postcard arrived at various media outlets across the city Postmarked from the town of Bright in northeast Victoria the writer of the postcards claimed to know who was responsible for the murders. The cards were forwarded to the Homicide Squad who wrote them off as a hoax.
现在物理证据排除了主要嫌疑人，案件似乎越来越不可能被解决了。然后，在1999年9月，全城的各个媒体机构收到了一张明信片。明信片上盖有维多利亚州东北部布莱特镇的邮戳，写信人声称知道谁应对谋杀案负责。这些卡片被转交给凶杀案调查组，他们将其视为恶作剧。
Then in early 2004 a series of letters arrived at the home of Suzanne Armstrong who was the head of the police department and a series of letters arrived at the home of Suzanne Armstrong's mother and stepfather. Written in scrolling cursive they were from the same person who'd authored the postcards four and a half years earlier. His name was Peter Collier and he openly criticised the police for not taking his previous claims seriously.
随后在2004年初，一系列信件寄到了苏珊·阿姆斯特朗母亲和继父的家中。信件用潦草的连体字书写，来自四年前写明信片的同一个人。他的名字叫彼得·科利尔，他公开批评警方没有认真对待他之前的说法。
As reported in the book Murder on Easy Street Peter had been a patient at Melbourne's La Rundle Psychiatric Hospital in early 1977. In late January his friend 30-year-old Anthony Thomas Christie was also admitted after attempting to end his own life. Christie spent 10 days in a coma before regaining consciousness. Three weeks later Peter was sitting in a group therapy session with seven other patients including Christie when Christie made a startling revelation.
正如《易街谋杀案》一书中所述，彼得在1977年初曾是墨尔本拉伦德精神病院的病人。1月下旬，他的朋友、30岁的安东尼·托马斯·克里斯蒂在试图自杀后也被收治。克里斯蒂在昏迷10天后恢复了意识。三周后，彼得正在与包括克里斯蒂在内的其他七名病人进行团体治疗，克里斯蒂做出了一个惊人的披露。
After having sex with women he felt an overwhelming desire to kill them with a carving knife. Peter was stunned. He started to put two and two together. He knew Christie had a criminal past and the timing of the suicide attempt had him questioning whether Christie could have committed the Easy Street murders and then tried to take his own life because of it.
在与女性发生性关系后，他有一种强烈的欲望想用切肉刀杀死她们。彼得惊呆了。他开始把事情联系起来。他知道克里斯蒂有犯罪前科，自杀未遂的时间点让他怀疑克里斯蒂是否犯下了易街谋杀案，并因此试图自杀。
In one of the letters to Suzanne's family Peter wrote This is only guesswork but I knew Christie and it's the only thing that makes sense to me. I don't believe for a moment that Suzanne was raped. It's possible but highly improbable. If you're capable of butchering two women you're capable of making out that one of them was raped.
在给苏珊家人的信中，彼得写道：“这只是猜测，但我认识克里斯蒂，这是唯一说得通的事情。我一点也不相信苏珊被强奸了。这有可能，但极不可能。如果你有能力屠杀两名女性，你就有能力伪造其中一人被强奸的假象。”
A far more likely scenario is that Suzanne and Christie were involved in pillow talk. He's told Suzanne that he's killed a couple of crimps. He'd hinted that to me. The women have decided to get rid of Christie and they have threatened him with the police. He's lost control. They're dead. What would have made him lose control?
“一个更有可能的情况是，苏珊和克里斯蒂在枕边谈话。他告诉苏珊他杀过几个罪犯。他曾向我暗示过这一点。女人们决定摆脱克里斯蒂，并威胁要报警。他失去了控制。她们死了。是什么让他失去了控制？”
He's hatred for the police. Peter explained that he didn't speak up at the time because he was suffering from poor mental health himself. He couldn't believe that the staff at La Rundle had failed to pass the information on to the relevant authorities. It haunted him to this day bolstered by the fact that Christie had since passed away without facing any consequences. In another letter, Peter wrote There is one way to get the truth out
“他对警察的仇恨。”彼得解释说，他当时没有说出来，是因为他自己的心理健康状况不佳。他无法相信拉伦德医院的工作人员竟然没有将这些信息传递给相关部门。这件事至今困扰着他，尤其是克里斯蒂后来在没有承担任何后果的情况下去世了。在另一封信中，彼得写道：“有一个方法可以查明真相，”
and that is to put it out on the internet that Anthony Thomas Christie is the Easy Street Killer. That would put some pressure on the creeps covering up the truth. Suzanne's family reported the information to police who dismissed Peter Collier's theory. Apparently this wasn't the first time he'd made these kinds of claims to bereaved family members. It wouldn't be the last time either. In November 2005, Easy Street was a buzz
“那就是在互联网上发布安东尼·托马斯·克里斯蒂是易街凶手的消息。这会给那些掩盖真相的混蛋施加一些压力。”苏珊的家人向警方报告了这些信息，但警方驳回了彼得·科利尔的理论。显然，这已经不是他第一次向悲痛的家属提出这类主张了。这也不会是最后一次。2005年11月，易街引起了轰动，
when several residents found a letter in their mailboxes from Peter. Written in black texta in all capitals, it read La Rundle Hospital protected Anthony Thomas Christie for the Easy Street murders for years. While it was clear that Peter had an ongoing fixation with the case there was no evidence to back his claims. Although if the killer was being held in a mental health facility that would explain why no similar crimes were committed after Suzanne Armstrong and Sue Bartlett's murders. That's one element that continues to baffle investigators.
当几位居民在信箱里发现了彼得的一封信时。信是用黑色记号笔全大写书写的，上面写着：“拉伦德医院多年来一直保护着易街谋杀案的凶手安东尼·托马斯·克里斯蒂。”虽然很明显彼得对该案有持续的执念，但没有证据支持他的说法。不过，如果凶手被关在精神卫生机构，那就能解释为什么在苏珊·阿姆斯特朗和苏·巴特利特遇害后没有发生类似的犯罪。这是令调查人员感到困惑的一个因素。
It just didn't seem plausible that someone could commit such an extreme brutal murder then go on to live a normal life without ever killing again. By January 2017, four decades had passed and police were still no closer to making an arrest. If anyone other than the killer knew who was responsible they had either taken their secret to the grave or continued to live with the knowledge. In the hopes of enticing someone to talk
一个人犯下如此极端残忍的谋杀案，然后继续过正常生活，再也没有杀过人，这似乎不太可能。到2017年1月，四十年过去了，警方在逮捕嫌疑人方面仍无进展。如果除了凶手之外还有人知道是谁干的，他们要么把秘密带进了坟墓，要么带着这个秘密继续生活。为了诱使某人开口，
Victoria Police announced a $1 million reward for information as well as possible indemnity against prosecution for anyone who came forward. A police spokesperson said we believe after 40 years someone out there knows something and it is time for them to come forward. These unsolved murders have been extremely devastating on these two young women's families and after all this time we would like to provide them with closure. For Suzanne Armstrong's family it was too little too late.
维多利亚警方宣布悬赏100万美元征集信息，并为提供线索的人提供可能的起诉豁免权。警方发言人表示：“我们相信40年后，有人知道一些事情，现在是他们站出来的时候了。这些悬案对这两个年轻女性的家庭造成了极大的破坏，经过这么长时间，我们希望能给他们一个交代。”对于苏珊·阿姆斯特朗的家人来说，这太迟了。
Suzanne's sister Gail was still disappointed about the way the case was handled from the get-go but she was grateful that the investigation was still active after all these years. She told reporters This reward should have been offered 39 years ago and it would be solved and we wouldn't be doing all this now. I hear the miracles that police do solve cases and I think Suzanne will be next. They will do it.
苏珊的姐姐盖尔仍然对案件从一开始的处理方式感到失望，但她很感激这么多年后调查仍在进行。她告诉记者：“这个悬赏应该在39年前就提供，那样案件早就破了，我们现在也不用做这些了。我听说警方创造奇迹破获了案件，我想苏珊会是下一个。他们会做到的。”
They will find this person. There were still 130 persons of interest on the list and a team was tasked with going through each individual in a bid to eliminate them once and for all. This was no easy task. Given how much time had passed 41 of those individuals had since passed away while others had relocated or changed addresses. Those who were able to be tracked down were encouraged to submit a voluntary DNA sample. The original eight suspects who had previously been cleared by DNA were also retested.
“他们会找到这个人的。”名单上仍有130名嫌疑人，一个团队被指派去逐一排查，试图一劳永逸地排除他们。这不是一项容易的任务。考虑到时间已经过去了这么久，其中41人已经去世，其他人则搬迁或更改了地址。那些能够被追踪到的人被鼓励自愿提交DNA样本。之前被DNA排除的最初八名嫌疑人也进行了重新测试。
Once again there were no matches. Despite the age of the DNA evidence it still holds the key to solving the Easy Street murders. Investigators in Victoria haven't yet turned to genealogy testing to solve cold cases but hope remains that the perpetrator could finally be identified via an ancestral link. Veteran journalist Tess Lawrence who visited Easy Street as family members packed up Suzanne and Sue's belongings has never revealed the name of the record that was on the turntable in the living room at the time of the murders. She has this information safely stored away on the off chance it might ever be useful to the investigation. Collingwood today is not the suburb it was back in the 1970s.
再一次，没有匹配结果。尽管DNA证据年代久远，但它仍然是解决易街谋杀案的关键。维多利亚州的调查人员尚未转向基因检测来解决悬案，但仍希望通过祖先联系最终确定肇事者。资深记者苔丝·劳伦斯在家人收拾苏珊和苏的遗物时曾访问过易街，她从未透露过谋杀发生时客厅唱机上那张唱片的名字。她将此信息安全地保存起来，以备万一它对调查有用。今天的科林伍德已不再是1970年代的那个郊区了。
It's now considered one of Melbourne's hippest areas. The old terrace homes remain but the warehouses that once defined the area have since been converted into trendy offices, bars and cafes. With its neighbouring house having since been demolished, number 147 Easy Street now stands alone. The house has changed hands multiple times over the years. When it sold in 2011, the real estate agent responsible for the sale found themselves in hot water after describing the house in their marketing campaign as part of Melbourne's folklore. A spokesperson for victim advocate group Support After Murder described this campaign as absolutely disgusting and accused the real estate agent of trying to capitalise on the tragedy. In their defence, the agent claimed they were just trying to fulfil disclosure requirements as discreetly as possible. At the time, Victorian law dictated that real estate agents only had to tell a prospective buyer about any violent crimes that occurred in a property if they were asked.
它现在被认为是墨尔本最时髦的地区之一。旧排屋依然存在，但曾经定义该地区的仓库已被改造成时尚的办公室、酒吧和咖啡馆。随着邻近的房子被拆除，易街147号现在孤零零地矗立着。多年来，这所房子几经易手。2011年出售时，负责销售的房地产经纪人在营销活动中将该房屋描述为“墨尔本民间传说的一部分”，这让他们陷入了困境。受害者权益组织“谋杀后支持”的发言人称这一活动“绝对令人作呕”，并指责房地产经纪人试图利用悲剧获利。经纪人辩称，他们只是试图尽可能谨慎地履行披露要求。当时，维多利亚州法律规定，房地产经纪人只有在被问及时，才必须告知潜在买家房产内发生的任何暴力犯罪。
Since then, the laws have changed so that agents must disclose these details no matter what. In 2017, 147 Easy Street sold again. The real estate ad described the house as, quote, enjoying a revitalised identity with a contemporary makeover while retaining its period luster. For years after Suzanne and Sue were killed, curious onlookers drove down Easy Street wanting to catch a glimpse of the infamous murder house. Teenagers would hang out of car windows while pointing and laughing, which upset the local residents who continued to be haunted by the crime. The notoriety of the gruesome crime itself often overshadows the fact that at the heart of the tragedy, two innocent young women lost their lives in the most brutal way imaginable, and their loved ones never received the closure they desperately sought. Sue Bartlett was well-liked with both students and colleagues at the Inner City High School where she worked.
从那以后，法律发生了变化，经纪人必须在任何情况下披露这些细节。2017年，易街147号再次出售。房地产广告将该房屋描述为“在保留其时代光泽的同时，享受着当代改造带来的焕然一新的身份”。在苏珊和苏遇害后的多年里，好奇的旁观者开车经过易街，想一睹臭名昭著的“谋杀屋”。青少年会从车窗探出头来指指点点并大笑，这让当地居民感到不安，他们继续被这起罪行所困扰。这起残忍罪行的恶名往往掩盖了一个事实：在悲剧的核心，两名无辜的年轻女性以最残忍的方式失去了生命，而她们的亲人从未得到他们迫切寻求的交代。苏·巴特利特在工作的市中心高中深受学生和同事的喜爱。
Dedicated to her job, she always went the extra mile to organise out-of-hours events for the kids such as school dances and other activities. If a faculty member was leaving, Sue was the one who hustled funds to buy them a farewell gift. In the wake of the murders, a former co-worker of Sue's rallied to raise funds in Sue's honour. The money was used to buy a painting of the Australian bush which hangs on the wall of the high school in memory of the popular and dedicated teacher. The co-worker remarked, When Suzanne Armstrong's son Gregory turned 18, he was finally able to access the $5,000 compensation payment that had been put into a trust. The money had been invested wisely, and by the time Gregory accessed it, it was worth almost $27,000. He used it to complete his education.
她工作敬业，总是竭尽全力为孩子们组织课外活动，如学校舞会和其他活动。如果有教职员工离职，苏总是那个奔走筹款为他们购买告别礼物的人。谋杀案发生后，苏的一位前同事筹集资金以纪念苏。这笔钱被用来购买一幅澳大利亚丛林画，挂在高中墙上，以纪念这位受欢迎且敬业的老师。这位同事评论道：“当苏珊·阿姆斯特朗的儿子格雷戈里年满18岁时，他终于能够支取存入信托基金的5000美元赔偿金。这笔钱投资得当，到格雷戈里支取时，价值已近27000美元。他用这笔钱完成了学业。”
Gregory doesn't speak publicly about his mother's murder, but in 1996 he formed a friendship with crime writer Tom Pryor, who penned a book about the case titled, They Trusted Men. Speaking to Tom, Gregory said, Everyone loses out on something. I've lost out because my mother was murdered. It has taken me a long time to realise how much I missed her. From all accounts, the last thing my mother could be described as was ordinary. I miss her. I wish I could meet my mother again, even just once. Suzanne's vibrant, inquisitive personality is forever captured in the letters she wrote to friends and family during her travels.
格雷戈里不公开谈论他母亲的谋杀案，但在1996年，他与犯罪作家汤姆·普赖尔建立了友谊，后者写了一本关于该案的书，名为《他们信任男人》。在与汤姆交谈时，格雷戈里说：“每个人都会失去一些东西。我失去了，因为我母亲被谋杀了。我花了好长时间才意识到我有多想她。据各方说法，我母亲最不可能是个普通人。我想她。我希望我能再见到我母亲，哪怕只有一次。”苏珊充满活力、好奇心强的个性永远定格在她旅行期间写给朋友和家人的信中。
While visiting Florida, he also wrote a letter to his mother. I think there are basically two ways to live your life, yours at home, and mine. Neither is really satisfactory 100%. It is just what you make of it. Happiness can only really bring happiness back to you. I think there are two ways to live your life, yours at home, and mine. Neither is really satisfactory 100%. It is just what you make of it. You only come from inside you, and you have to know people. I haven't found such happiness, but I am getting to know myself, and that is an interesting experience.
在访问佛罗里达时，他也给母亲写了一封信：“我想生活基本上有两种方式，你在家里的那种，和我的。没有哪种是100%令人满意的。这取决于你如何去过。幸福只能真正带给你幸福。我想生活有两种方式，你在家里的那种，和我的。没有哪种是100%令人满意的。这取决于你如何去过。你只能来自你的内心，你必须了解人们。我还没有找到这样的幸福，但我正在了解自己，那是一次有趣的经历。”
Life is really crazy, but I do believe there is a purpose to everything. Whatever it is, I can't say. But I suppose I will find out. Soon enough. Thank you for watching. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“生活真的很疯狂，但我确实相信一切皆有目的。无论是什么，我说不出来。但我相信我会发现的。很快。感谢观看。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。”